[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and this is
episode zero by which I mean it's not a
regular episode it's more like a teaser
trailer trying to give you the general
overview of Who I am what we're gonna be
doing over the course of the podcast I
want to confess I was tempted to
dedicate episode zero to an hour-long
disquisition on the nature of
rationality that would be very true to
who I am but I thought that we're
getting to know each other we're
starting a new endeavor over here maybe
I should try to keep things short and
sweet not give people too much of the
right idea and try to get to the bottom
of why I would even do this in the first
place
you know by vocation I'm a physicist I
work at Caltech right now I do
theoretical physics that is to say I
think about quantum mechanics space time
the nature of the universe increasingly
these days I'm thinking about complex
systems entropy information theory and
things like that but I've been
interested in lots of things for much
longer than that not just physics
philosophy economics literature art
history all sorts of different things
and as an academic I'm not really
allowed to think about those things in a
professional capacity I'm allowed to
think them about them in my spare time
but my job is thinking about theoretical
physics and in the meantime I've been on
plenty of podcasts you know from Joe
Rogan to the rights to Ricky Sanchez
always had a good time as someone who
enjoys doing new and interesting things
I've often thought about doing it myself
but the usual things got in the way it's
not my job how much time would it take
and so forth what finally pushed me
nudged me over towards actually doing it
is the idea that these podcast hosts get
to talk to whoever they want as long as
they can get them to say yes on the
podcast but there's no restrictions on
topic they can talk about basketball if
they're a basketball podcast if they
want to
but they could also talk about other
things people don't have to listen it's
okay so I realized that this for me
would be a license to talk about all
sorts of ideas that I don't get to
confront and deal with as an academic in
my day to day environment not writing
papers about them not being an expert
myself but talking to the world's
experts both other academics and people
in other fields of endeavor really smart
people who are working on some of the
most interesting ideas out there so
that's going to be the focus of this
podcast in terms of format it's pretty
conventional I'm expecting most of the
episodes will be me interviewing one
other person sometimes it will just be
me talking about something I have
something to say about but mostly it'll
be me picking someone who I think has
something really interesting to say and
rather than looking for fun personal
anecdotes or jumping from topic to topic
really digging into a particular big
idea a particular thing that we'd like
to get to the bottom two of and a
popular level in the sense that should
be accessible to everyone no special
technical jargon presumed to be known
but in a way that we have time enough to
really get into it to really try to
understand what's going on so for me
that's where the fun is it's very
unlikely that someone like Lady Gaga is
going to be a guest on this podcast but
if she did she did come on I wouldn't be
asking her about celebrity gossip or the
latest thing that was going on I would
ask her about performance and writing
and the artistry of being a rock star a
pop star in the modern age everyone has
something interesting to say if they're
at the top of their profession in that
way so by the way Gaga if you're
listening to this we would love to have
you on the podcast have your people
contact my people we will definitely set
that up but meanwhile whether or not
anyone else is interested in these
things one of the things about this
format that appeals to me is that I will
get to learn something I will get to
learn smart ideas from very interesting
people hopefully I will also get better
at dealing with ideas that I'm both
unfamiliar with myself or even disagree
with myself you know in the modern world
especially when we have the Internet to
mediate many of our conversation
we're not always good at confronting and
thinking about things that we don't
immediately agree with whether it's
anger and dismissiveness or just sarcasm
or snark we tend to respond instantly
and unreflective ly to such ideas and I
bring this up not to accuse anybody else
but to say that I've been very bad about
this I'm as just as guilty as anybody
else of being snarky or dismissive when
something comes along I don't agree with
and I think it's important to disagree
with things sometimes but I would like
to usually disagree with them in a
thoughtful careful considered way so
that's the kind of thing I'm gonna be
looking for on the podcast I'm sure I
will be often interviewing people who I
do agree with but hopefully they'll be
more than enough people who challenge me
in some way and I'm gonna try to get
better at dealing with those in a way
that is useful that it's useful to me
and useful to everyone listening and
with that in mind I do have something I
want to say about the nature of
rationality if you've gotten this far
into it indulge me a little bit because
I think this is important here's the
thing about rationality it's hard it's
hard to be reasonable about things not
utterly not reasonable at all we can be
slightly rational about things but being
perfectly rational is very very hard the
human brain was not trained to do this
we grew up over evolutionary time scales
to solve certain problems and logical
reasoning wasn't always among those
problems very few human beings could
take the square root of a 10 digit
number but any pocket calculator can do
that with no problem there's other
things we human brains are very good at
but not simple mathematical logical kind
of constructions interestingly the human
brain is very efficient
computationally human physicists know
that when you have a computational
process that includes both analyzing
information but also recording it and
deleting it from a hard drive this
creates heat you might have noticed this
in your computer your laptop sitting on
your lap heats up if you have a gaming
rig you need to spend money to keep it
cool this is the generation of entropy
this is the second law of thermodynamics
in action all computational processes do
this but some do it more efficiently
than others the human brain it turns out
is actually really efficient unlike your
laptop even when you're thinking really
hard your brain doesn't melt part of
that efficiency is that the human brain
is not just brute forcing its
calculations it's taking shortcuts we
develop heuristics and rules of thumb to
deal with the universe and these are
usually very helpful but sometimes they
lead us astray sometimes they lead us to
for example cognitive biases most people
have heard for example of the idea of
confirmation bias if you like an idea if
you want it to be true you tend to look
at evidence that favors that idea you
tend to not pay attention to evidence
that goes against it and the subject of
cognitive bias and how we deal with it
how we train ourselves to do better in
the face of these biases has been very
very well studied there's something that
I don't think has been as well studied
which is another aspect of rationality
namely what we pay attention to in the
first place when I was an undergraduate
I took a philosophy class and one of my
philosophy professors started one of the
lectures by saying how many facts are
there in this room right now how many
facts it's kind of a rhetorical question
there's no answer to that question or
the answer is just infinity even if
there's only a finite number of things
in the room there's an infinite number
of things that might be in the room but
aren't right the fact that there is no
elephant in the room is a fact and this
simple fact about facts is something
that has enormous implications for how
we think how we try to make sense of our
world we ask journalists or scientists
to be objective in what they do and we
don't quite give credit to how
impossible it is to be fully objective
when a journalist reports something they
can be objective about the facts they
report they can report facts truthfully
and accurately but there's necessarily a
subjective component to deciding what
facts to report whenever we tell a story
about something we are choosing what
aspects to emphasize and this choice is
seemingly automatic but it can be
trained out of us psychologists have
done studies for example where they show
people a picture and they say we're
gonna ask
you questions about this picture so
study it carefully and they look at how
people's eyes track across the picture
to no one's surprise really professional
artists look at pictures very
differently than non artists do regular
human beings tend to look at people they
look at the faces of people or they look
at other animals artists who are trained
are much better at giving equal
attention to different parts of the
foreground and background of a picture
and this idea of training our attention
I think is really crucial to becoming
more rational in this complicated world
with our imperfect brains let me just
give you two examples that sort of span
the spectrum from science to high
emotional impact human drama on the
science end of things there's the
question of interpretations of quantum
mechanics this question has its own
human drama in it also but it's one of
my favorite scientific questions you
might know that quantum mechanics is our
best theory of how the world works at a
deep level you might also know that
physicists don't agree on what it is
that quantum mechanics says
fundamentally about what reality is and
how it works
so we have competing formulations of the
theory my favorite formulation is what's
called the many-worlds formulation I'm
writing a book about that I'm sure we'll
talk about it in the podcast but the
basic idea is that when you make a
quantum measurement there's different
possible outcomes and each one of those
outcomes becomes real in a separate
world now there's many reasons to like
this to not like it good reasons bad
reasons I think that one of the reasons
why some people don't like it which may
be is not what they articulate but is
nevertheless there is that in this
many-worlds formulation there's a huge
gap between the mathematical formalism
and the world we immediately see if you
ask someone who believes in many worlds
what is nature at its most fundamental
level they'll tell you something like it
is a quantum state described by a vector
in a very high dimensional complex
Hilbert space an ordinary person will
say I don't get it
the the world around me has tables and
chairs and objects and things like that
where are those things where is
space-time itself in your hands
quantum formalism so there are competing
formulations of quantum mechanics where
the tangible things of everyday life are
much more front-and-center much more
evident where they're located in the
formalism and I think that there's a
matter of taste that comes in here if
you're if what you care about most of
what you pay attention to most in a
scientific theory is the directness with
which that theory accounts for the world
that you see around you then you're
going to try to favor a interpretation
of quantum mechanics that puts those
acts but aspects right in the foreground
if what you care about more in a
scientific theory is the underlying
formalism is it powerful is it simple is
it mathematically elegant then
many-worlds is your bet everyone agrees
even people who don't think that many
worlds is right everyone agrees that
it's underlying formalism is as simple
as you can possibly get so there is a
matter of taste it's not just a matter
of equations or experimental data
because we're talking about two
different theories we don't know which
one is right someday we'll figure out
which one is right but until we do your
personal what you pay attention to
question is really really important when
we favor or disfavor one version of
quantum mechanics over the other the
other end of the spectrum let's look at
sexual harassment you may know this is
2018 there's been a lot of effort
recently a lot of news about people in
very high-profile places who have been
accused of sexual harassment with
enormous amounts of evidence against
them really credible accusations of
sexual harassment and they got in
trouble for this and rightfully so and
this has been true especially you know
we've heard about Hollywood but it's
also been true in physics and astronomy
and academia a famous example is Jeffrey
Marcin who is an exoplanet researcher he
looked at planets around other stars the
other than the Sun and he was very
famous in line for the Nobel Prize he
was very successful and a couple years
ago it came to light that he was a
serial sexual harasser going back many
many years there's a Norris amounts of
evidence against him and he resigned his
position at UC Berkeley etc but when the
news first broke there was an email that
went around to the faculty at Berkeley
from the
department chair so his boss in some
sense and the email I'll quote we what
it said it said of course this is
hardest for Jeff in this moment for
those who are willing and able he
certainly can use any understanding or
support you may offer now other people
pointed out fairly quickly that maybe a
sexual harassment situation is actually
not hardest on the harasser maybe is
hardest on the victims of the harassment
people who might have had their lives
ruined left the field really suffered
from depression or questioned who they
were or whatever if something like this
has happened for many many years it can
be very devastating to many other people
and yet that was not what occurred to
the department chair when he was roading
this letter what occurred to him was his
friend and colleague was going to be
upset and that is correct he I'm sure he
was upset I'm sure it was hard on him
the difference is what are you paying
attention to and I think this goes
beyond the specific example and I don't
think even the department chair was
especially evil or conniving about it I
think it's a simple matter that when
we're faced with a situation like this
our attention immediately leaps
somewhere right when we hear that
someone famous or someone we respected
or knew personally been accused of
something terrible does our attention
immediately go to the victims of that
terrible thing they did or does our
attention immediately go to well what
about them what about the person being
accused was it a wrongful accusation are
they being treated fairly and there's no
right or wrong here in some sense we can
all learn to sympathise across the board
a little bit better than we do
but this underlying issue of what we pay
attention to what matters to us is to me
a crucially a crucially important part
of being more rational of understanding
the world better I'm hopefully hopeful
this will be a theme in the podcast
across the episodes not just what is
this good idea what is this interesting
finding a little bit less of this sort
of whiz-bang latest news from the
science frontier kind of stuff and more
like why are we doing this why are we
thinking about this why is this
interesting to us why is this important
and hopefully as I said along the way
not only will I learn things but I might
even change my mind I could be wrong
about any of my favorite ideas
so will certainly be useful for me I'm
hoping will be equally interesting for
you people out there at their very least
I think the journey will be a lot of fun
thanks for joining along
[Music]
you
[Music]